Some people who have taken psychedelics have
described their experience as entering god
mode, transcending human perception, or reaching
a higher state of consciousness.
But ... what’s actually going on inside
the brain?
To find out, a recent study gave volunteers
intravenous doses of either LSD, psilocybin
or ketamine.
Then they did exactly what you’d think they’d
do: lock their tripping volunteers in a loud,
claustrophobic machine to scan their brains.
The researchers found their brain activity
was more random and less integrated, which
could explain the randomness of thought that
reportedly happens under the influence of
psychedelics.
They also found that these compounds affected
parts of the brain that deal with perception.
Essentially, parts of the brain that didn’t
normally communicate were saying, “Hey There!,”
creating what they called a “mixing of the
senses,” sort of like a chemically induced
synaesthesia.
The researchers called this a “higher state
of consciousness,” which coincidentally
is what hippies or monks might call this state
of mind.
But the researchers made a point to say that
"higher" does not mean "better" or more "desirable.”
Instead, this is just the first time we've
measured brain-signal diversity that's higher
than normal.
And that more research is likely needed!
Anyone who’s even seen a movie about someone
who’s been on these drugs understands they’re
experiencing an altered state of consciousness.
But now, we have data.
Ketamine, Psilocybin and LSD have different
pharmacological properties, but in this study,
they all produced changes in the neural signal
diversity, which is a measure of how complex
brain activity is.
Ketamine seems to have the widest effect on
the brain, while psilocybin affects only a
very small section.
In the field of neuroscience, these compounds
are slowly becoming tools to help researchers
find the molecular basis of consciousness.
Just like sleep research, psychedelics are
a window into the brain at a different state.
For example, in a separate study researchers
found the principal nodes in the brain’s
default mode network, which is an interconnected
group of brain structures that creates your
sense of self, are disrupted under the influence
of psilocybin and LSD.
These changes in brain activity are why users
often report a temporary loss of self or “ego
dissolution.”
What that means is, the brain’s central
compass, the inner voice you have that drives
your behavior is quieted.
The neurons that usually work together lose
synchronization, and that is what the researchers
think creates an entirely different conscious
experience.
We still don’t know what parts of the brain
are responsible for generating consciousness.
I mean, the brain is one of the most complex
structures in the universe with over 100 to
500 trillion synapses.
We have our work cut out for us.
Understanding how brain activity reorients
could have therapeutic potential.
The default mode network is overactive in
people who are prone to depression and pessimistic
patterns of thinking, which is why psilocybin
is being explored as an antidepressant.
And that’s the key for these researchers.
By seeing how the brain lights up under different
drugs and understanding the changes in brain
activity, there’s hope that these compounds
could alleviate hard to treat neurological
conditions.
Psychedelics are a tool to tweak consciousness
and gather more data.
We have so many pictures of normal brains,
but by tweaking things a little (and understanding
what’s happening), we get better insight
into how the brain does this amazing thing
that it’s doing for you and me right now.
Special thanks to our sponsor, Domain.com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain.com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 15% off Domain.com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
Ketamine, LSD, and psilocybin are known to
cause hallucinations, but you don’t need
drugs to have a good time, if by have a good
time you mean see crazy imagined things.
Trace and I talk about hallucinations here.
What do you think about the potential for
using these chemicals to understand how consciousness
forms? Let us know in the comments, subscribe for more, and I will see you
next time on Seeker.